- So, are you amazed
with how much, I mean,
people still love "The
Notebook", they still talk.
It's just one of the most
gigantic love stories.
Did you know, did you have an inkling that
this is gonna connect
when you were writing it?
It's hard to say, I guess, now.
- You know, when I was writing it,
I thought it had a chance.
It was funny, you know.
It was a story originally inspired
by my wife at the time,
Kathy, her grandparents.
And I remember seeing how
much they cared for each other
toward the end of their life,
and it was a story that moved me.
And as I'm there typing,
I hoped people would get
it, but one never knows.
- You don't, yeah.
- I had no agent.
I knew nothing about
publishing at the time.
- Wow, geez.
- I was working.
- What?
I didn't know that.
- Yeah, I was working
full time.
And then we had a young baby at the time
who didn't sleep well,
so I had time in the evening to write
since Kathy would go to sleep.
And, so I wrote "The
Notebook" in my spare time.
- In your spare time.
Just wrote "The Notebook", it's fine.